hello
dang
thank you
there are pairs snapping on my oscar
edition Air Jordans give it to me
get to me by the great Michael Jordan
for his occasion don't hate but what an
honor
look at it Denzel buy more house brawl
Samuel Jackson what's these Snipes
goddamn [ __ ] alright well I got a you
know you guys when you chose that song
had changing to come yeah it's been a
long time coming so I want to thank
Cheryl Boone Isaacs the president of the
Academy motion pics aren't scientists
trying to bring some flavor up in here
we need some flavor up in here I want to
thank the board governance
I'm very sorry Debbie Reynolds not here
tonight would love to meet her in person
and and Jena as I honor
and I know one's doneness by got to give
look my table because people come long a
long way mr. gene Friedman my mandolin
Dylan my agent 20 Howard our partner
David Yarnell one of Brooklyn's Finest
mr. John Tudor Oh my longtime Medusa
John Killick
the wonderful Latonya Richardson Jax
where you'll science my sibling David
Lee Sang Keely jawad now David I know if
you look in the de for deGrasse earlier
he has been my noona photographer from
film school and why use all those great
photographs of me he took I told me
needs to make a book my sisters while
many of my films my brothers Sankey Jack
Sankey Lee who's the videographer my
sister Laura tres elegant my two
children who are now in film school they
go to my alma mater where I'm a tenured
professor tenured for 15 years I'm a
teaching film a new University graduate
film school so thank you my great
wonderful in-laws George Lillian Lewis
my father is not he's able he not able
to be here tonight
and then my lovely strong partner wife
Tanya time stand up Nana
now if you see my body at work I call it
BT and 18 so you see my body work before
Tanya and after Tanya dealing with women
you could tell where I got married so
thank you for that all right I'm going
to take my time as they say in church
take your time
a little bit how I get here why I was
born the line a Georgia boy grew up in
Brooklyn New York
and my mother my late mother who died I
was in film school she was the one that
your name is Jacqueline Shelton Lee she
was the one introduced me to film my
father great jabba's ition he hated
movies so I was my mother's date and she
would drag me to movies and so my
introduction that marseilles see when
she took me to see Mean Streets went
away to college alma mater Sam Morehouse
College I'm a third generation Morehouse
man my grandfather went to morons my
father went to Morehouse he was a
freshman Martin Luther King was a senior
and my grandmother and my mother went to
Spelman these are two historic black
schools across from each other across
treat each other in Atlanta Georgia
of course Sam's wife is from Spelman so
I went to go into college I know what I
want to do but I had to go to college
had to go to Morehouse so my first two
years I was lost in the wilderness I was
a d + C - student it was because I was
small just not motivated so the end of
my sophomore year my advisor said before
it's time to go back home for the summer
go back to New York so you would think
long and hard about choosing major and I
said why she said because you'll
exhausted all your electives
so I came back to New York
viii miss summer of 1977 and I thought
up to that point you always get a job in
New York
you had your working papers but that
summer 1977 New York City was broke
there's a famous Daily News front page
for the city does President Ford Ford
the city drop dead there were no jobs so
I didn't want to sit on my stoop play
strat-o-matic baseball all summer no one
heard about strut no one played
strat-o-matic baseball back here come on
somebody anyway my team was in 1953
Brooklyn Dodgers so that summer it was
crazy it's really crazy because that
summer I end up making them feel about
that summer summer Sam's you never know
how this stuff works so one day I'm in
my stupid we call him Stoops not Portis
in Brooklyn and I'm gonna say let me go
see my friend viateur Davis now she was
very smart New York City Polk high
school is like this Stuyvesant Bronx
Science and Brooklyn Tech and she was a
genius I mean she's right didn't there
she knew she won't be a doctor end up
going to Princeton to Harvard med school
she's a doctor not a cop anyway I'm
gonna say let me see what she's doing so
I go to her house and I ring the bell
she has come on up and was sitting in
the living room and in the corner is a
box and I say what's in the box
she says the super 8 camera I'm gonna be
a doctor so you can have it Nessa what's
in the other box he says that's film for
super 8 camera I'm the doctor you can
have it so now he has something to do
for the summer I was not the placed
rally medic baseball on the stoop all
summer and so was the great summer of
the shoot because a couple of days later
there was a blackout
it's black out and so my father drove me
around we have a we had a situation
yellow Citroen station wagon so my
fellow brothers and sisters my fellow
Puerto Rican brother says estar de Loup
I filmed it I we not 123 120 feet of
Harlem filling the balloon and when the
full Street in Brooklyn choice signs
with color TVs wash machines pampers and
Walt Frazier collide Pullman's and so I
film that and then that summer in summer
1977 was the first summer disco so every
block weekends people hooking up their
turntables speakers to the street lamps
I was filming that and then there was a
guy named David Berkowitz Son of Sam so
yet most New York terrified see this is
before justification so back in 1977 the
Son of Sam would have come into Harlem
bed-stuy
they would have killed him before just
way way back for gentle acacia so I have
all this footage and I go back to school
and I say I'm gonna be a master cases
major and there's a cheetah there who
still teach that today is named dr. herb
Eichelberger he encouraged me to make a
documentary of his footage the film is
called
Last House on Brooklyn from then my
junior and seniors I was an A+ student I
always seems yeah but the reason why I
didn't get any smarter I just was
interesting so I don't say I found film
filmed found me moving forward I'm going
I graduate I know that story about
working way up from the middle doesn't
work for black people so I say I'm going
to try to go to film school so I applied
a USC AFI and I don't get in USC or AFI
because I don't have the astronomical
score on the GRE
but lucky for me that had more for
thinking people NYU who said whether you
determine whether in the film that
should be determined by a standardized
test so I got into are you and that's
why I met Ernest Dickerson great great
DP Ernst and I were the only two people
in the program and we bonded automatics
I went to Howard I'm seeing that with
the Morehouse and he went to Howard and
here's the thing I'd like to say the
reason Ernest and I were successful
because our parents told us from a very
early age that we had to be 10 times
better than not white classmates that
just being the same was not going to be
enough that was instilled for me from
the beginning that we the people here if
you're trying on you got to be better
you have to extra so you have to excel
so come on nothing's changed that's Dee
right there the man
so three years of film school I do a
film my thesis numbers called Joe's best
our barbershop and the wins the student
kami award I won the student County
Award back in 1983 so I had an agent man
I thought that spear books bill Burson
call me Lucas Fox Universal and it had a
little apartment of burlap on four green
before identification so I had my now
the student kami Ward is not like this
it's a wooden box with the circle with
this on it so I know for sure because I
have a student County Ward I'm gonna
take over Hollywood but a funny thing
happens when you don't pay my bail you
don't take on Edison you don't play
Brooklyn Ewing gas
the phone is turned off the heat gets
turned off and lights to turn on so I
was in the darkness by having my student
Cammie Award and then I woke up and so
that's when I learned the tough less
that nothing happens overnight there's
no such thing as overnight success and
that's the biggest thing we do to our
young people tell them but there's a
thing in the animal as or like said you
have to bust your ass roll up your
sleeves and attack attack attack attack
every single day and national I can tell
my film students NYU could last 15 years
let me turn a pager to Mordy so at this
point so I like to say I'm very happy
you know this is a great night make
families here have many friends people I
work with but it's not been easy and I
and I'm just as proud as this award as a
people we got in this industry but
behind and front of the camera that was
always a goal it's like if I got in I
was gonna try and bring as many
[ __ ] with me as possible
we like public any bum-rush the show
Koza come in here
Malcolm X would give me shoot Malcolm X
and we're meeting with the Teamsters I
say Sir Tom Oh Tommy O'Donnell
I said sir you have any black Teamsters
he says no I said that's a problem I
said until you get some black Teamsters
we're going to have the fruit of Islam
drive trucks and if you want to come to
the set and folk with the fruit of Islam
come on next day five black teams showed
up but some people don't do that but I
don't care about that I knew I had to
make change like that or wouldn't be we
are today in closing
in closing I always say this but it's
been redundant then please forgive me I
want to thank my grandmother Sam you met
my grandma
zippy Shelton Lee she her grandmother
was a slave yes she graduated with the
college degree and for 50 years she
taught art van Gogh was her favorite
painter the fifth year she taught art in
the state of Georgia in 50 years she
never had one white student because the
Jim Crow laws in that state and the 50
years white students missed on a great
art teacher and for 50 years my
grandmother's saved her Social Security
checks for her grandchildren's education
and since I was the firstborn I had
first dibs so my grandmother through 50
years a saving her Social Security
Social Security checks put me through
Morehouse put me through NYU film school
gave me the money for my thesis film and
then gave me the money for she's got to
have it
and I want to commend the president
Cheryl Boone Isaacs because she is
trying to do something needs to be done
have you noticed but the United States
Census Bureau says about a year 2040
2040 three white Americans are going to
be minority in this country and all the
people out there who are imposition of
hiring you better get smart because your
workforce to reflect what this country
looks about what this color looks like
and I'm going to get real here a lot of
everybody in here probably voted for
Obama but when I go to offices
I see no black folks except brother man
at the security security guard who
checks my name of the list as I go into
the studio so we could talk you know
Yabba Yabba Yabba but we need to have
some serious discussion about diversity
and get some flavor up in this this
industry is so behind sports is
ridiculous it's easier to beat the
President on States as a black person
then be the head of studio honest it's
easier to be the President on stage and
be head of a studio or head of a network
let's leave all out of it she doesn't
count
so president keep it going I know it's
tough we've got a long way to go
peace love the people in France and the
last thing is Brooklyn in the house
Brooklyn's in the house thank you very
much